here to tell us more about managing
stress in everyday life is professor
Isabel at Heiser she's a psychiatrist at
the charity hospital here in Berlin
thank you so much for joining us here in
the studio now this restaurant owner in
the report was really stressed but he
didn't even know her to notice it
himself how can he have not noticed it
when it's so risky for him well that's a
pretty regular occurrence that people
subjectively don't notice that they are
in a you know stressed out actually
whereas the objective data tell us
something else is there any definitive
proof out there that you know stress
really is behind any one particular
illness oh yes I think that there is no
doubt that if you are if you're very
stressed and if you are living under
chronic stressful conditions if you have
everyday stress like daily hassles then
you have a much higher risk to develop
depression severe depression or a
cardiovascular disorder like heart
attack or strokes so that commute into
work or whatever it might be that
happens every other day actually could
lead to one of these diseases or
problems and that has been shown in
multiple studies do you distinguish
between physiological and psychological
stress no we don't do that because
psychological stress always translates
of course into physiological or
metabolic changes so for example if you
experience what you called psychological
stress then your body reacts to that
there's adrenaline there's cortisol
that's being secreted sleep is going to
be disturbed by that the blood pressure
rises pulse rises so there's a lot of
bodily changes going on when you have
psychological stress but for example
these effects or these hormones these
stress hormones we can't actually live
without them either no we can't and we
are not supposed to actually because it
gives us drive it gives us the energy
it gives us the motivation to go on but
I there's always the question how long
do you want to go on you have to have
periods of relaxation that is very
important that you relax and give you a
body a chance to recuperate if you will
how do you know then when this stress is
enough at this point how do you regulate
that well you can't really do that but
or or it's not so easy but you should be
very aware of the fact that there is a
sign if you are a sign telling you that
this might there might be a problem with
chronic stressful conditions that you
are living in if you have difficulties
falling asleep or sleeping through the
night or if you can only sleep at night
fall asleep at night when you have
alcohol which is not recommended
actually so this is these are these are
subtle signs that you might be in living
in stressful conditions can the body
actually adapt to a high level of stress
and then become immune to it somehow no
it kept definitely not definitely not
and how about breaking down the stress
in the body then apart from getting a
good night's sleep relaxation is there
any other advice or tips out there for
people who are suffering from severe
stress yes there is there's another tip
that you should follow maybe do mild
physical activity you know nothing
stressful yeah don't go into
competitions or anything but just have a
nice walk with somebody you like
Isabella hoy say thank you so much for
joining us here in studio today you're
welcome